The golden age of classic Western films may
be over, but a new kind of Western has established
its place in the world of prestige TV.
Whether you're a huge fan already or you're
just getting into it, here's everything we
know so far about Yellowstone season 3.
By the Yellowstone season 2 finale, Kayce
Dutton and Monica's son Tate had been kidnapped,
and the Duttons were on a mission to bring
him home at any cost.
They track down Teal and Malcolm Beck, knowing
that the two businessmen have something to
do with the disappearance.
"If there's a Heaven, this is your last chance
to do something that just might get you in
it."
Teal won't confess, so Kayce makes good on
John's promise to shoot him.
Malcolm is willing to give up some details,
but he suffers a few gunshot wounds and is
presumably left for dead.
It turns out that Tate has been kidnapped
by white supremacists who were hired by the
Becks.
By the time Kayce finds him, he's already
been beaten and traumatized.
But with the mystery of his abduction solved,
he can finally return home.
In a heartwarming moment, John's daughter
Beth reads his right-hand man Rip Wheeler
a letter from John, explaining that he's leaving
Rip his father's old ranch house in exchange
for saving Beth from a pair of attackers.
Keith Cox, Paramount Network and TV Land President
of Development and Production, says the network
has grand visions for season 3 and beyond,
and he's impressed with the scripts he's read
so far.
He told Deadline:
"It's going to be great and even bigger than
Season 2; I know it, feel it.
It will happen."
Cox also says that the final ending for the
series is already planned, discussions about
an eventual season 4 are ongoing, and the
show will ideally run for six or seven seasons
total.
Costner has made it clear that there will
be further consequences for those who threatened
the Dutton family in season 2, so it looks
like karma will be coming around.
Meanwhile, Beth and Rip appear to be diving
back into their rekindled romance.
Fans theories abound regarding Jamie's possible
past interference in their relationship, so
perhaps season 3 will address some of the
rumors.
But expect some big changes going from season
2 into season 3.
"You can try to find a way to play it safe,
and there isn't."
The cast has noted that season 3 will start
off slow, but it won't stay that way for long.
"It's a slow burn, and then it heats up."
Fans who are worried that the show won't feel
quite the same can rest assured that they're
in for a great season.
"Season 3 is some of my favorite stuff so
far.
It's pretty shocking."
It looks like all of the main cast members
appear to be returning for Yellowstone season
3.
Naturally, you won't be seeing Terry Serpico
as Teal anymore, but there's still a slim
chance that Neal McDonough could return as
Malcolm — remember, he didn't actually die
on camera.
This season, a few other recurring actors
will be bumped up to regular roles.
Forrie J. Smith, who plays Dutton's cow boss
Lloyd, is officially being promoted to a series
regular, along with Denim Richards, who plays
cowboy wrangler Colby.
It's safe to say we'll be seeing a lot more
of Lloyd and Colby in the upcoming season.
Kevin Costner may be stepping behind the camera
on occasion throughout this season as well.
In a recent interview with Deadline, Costner
expressed his hope that he would be able to
focus on directing in the future.
Josh Holloway will be appearing as Roarke
Carter, a charismatic hedge fund manager with
big plans in Montana — plans that just might
involve the Dutton ranch.
Holloway has described his character as, quote,
"a hedge fund baller," with Costner adding:
"You can't ignore him, you can't just kind
of close the gate."
Deadline notes that Holloway's character will
have a "season-long" arc, so it doesn't look
like he'll be sticking around for a probable
season 4.
It's hinted that Carter might try to make
a move on Beth, and Kelly Reilly expressed
excitement at working with Holloway.
Perhaps Carter is trying to take control of
the land for himself and wants to curry favor
with Beth as an "in" with the Duttons.
Or maybe he'll prove to be an unlikely ally
for the Duttons in the face of another adversary.
John Emmet Tracy is also slated to appear
in a recurring role as Ellis Steele, a chief
litigator for Fortune 500 companies.
Described as, quote, "the kind of person who
will smile as he stabs you in the back," Steele
could pose a serious threat to the Dutton
ranch.
Q'orianka Kilcher will be playing Angela Blue
Thunder, a Native American woman who opposes
Tom Rainwater, the chief of the reservation.
Angela is disgusted with the way Rainwater
has been running the casino, and she feels
that he's responsible for many of the problems
on the reservation.
Whether or not Angela's bold actions against
Rainwater will benefit the Duttons is unclear.
But considering his past intentions to acquire
their land to expand the reservation, the
enemy of their enemy might be their friend
in this scenario.
"Working with them is a deal with the devil,
Dad."
"All the angels are gone, son.
There's only devils left."
A new wrangler will be working on the Dutton
ranch in season 3.
Jennifer Landon is joining the cast as Teeter,
an accomplished wrangler who may be a bit
rough around the edges, but always gets the
job done.
It's likely she'll be working alongside Colby
and Lloyd.
Teeter won't be the first female ranch hand
to work for the Duttons — after all, Avery
was already recruited to work there by Rip
in the first season.
But it does look like she'll be just the kind
of no-nonsense woman who can hold her own
on the ranch.
Eden Brolin will be another new addition to
the cast.
She has a recurring role as Mia, a barrel
racer who strikes up a friendship with the
bunkhouse guys.
Brolin is most widely known for playing Charlie
in the Freeform series Beyond, in which a
young man awakens from a coma to find that
he has inexplicable powers connecting him
to a dark conspiracy.
Her work on Yellowstone is just another sign
that she's definitely a star on the rise and
one to watch in the next year.
Finally, Karen Pittman is confirmed to have
a major role in season 3.
She'll be playing Willa Hays, the CEO of Metro
Capital.
She's well-dressed, intimidating, and never
backs down from what she wants.
Now, she wants something from John Dutton
— and she's going to fight tooth and nail
to get it.
There's a possibility that Ellis Steele is
representing her as she tries to acquire the
Duttons' land.
With so many new female characters coming
to the ranch, it looks like the women will
be running things.
Overall, it's shaping up to be an incredible
follow-up to an addictive second season.
You can catch up on the first two seasons
of Dutton family drama on Amazon Prime.
Season 3 of Yellowstone premieres on the Paramount
Network on June 17, 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.